a looming partial shutdown of the
government could disrupt essential
services used by millions of Americans
over the holidays president Trump and
Congress have until December 20th to
strike a deal to keep the government
open in the new paperback edition of the
fifth risk best-selling author Michael
Lewis reveals the personal toll on
federal workers of the record-breaking
shutdown that began last year and
Michael Lewis joins us at the table now
Michael good morning thanks for having
me so this is a great book the first
time around it's even better now they've
got this afterward which is the story I
like it it's a major contribution
actually sometimes it's like an
afterword it's just a couple pages this
is great it's a story of art Alan yeah
it was a major part of search and rescue
for the Coast Guard I think he's really
important and you can talk about why but
in part because we had this idea of the
government as being kind of incompetent
bloated too big a bureaucracy
ineffective people and art Alan is the
opposite of all that it's so easy to
dismiss until you see what the people
are actually doing and why they're doing
it not soaking attention not shaking
taste so I found this guy grabbed him
basically out of a hat during the last
shutdown because he had been deemed out
of a lot of people who've been deemed in
essential it's like what who was in
essential so what did this guy done it
he'd spent 35 years in the Coast Guard
devoted to essentially to one problem
that was trying to figure out how
objects drifted on the sea because if
you can't you can't figure out how they
drift you can't figure out where they
are and Americans Americans have like
this amazing ability to get lost at sea
like can get rescued three died and that
before our talons start doing what he
did that many more died and and and he
spent you know on his own initiative one
guy the lone oceanographer in the Coast
Guard spent years dropping stuff in the
Long Island Sound and figuring out how a
sail boat floated versus a man overboard
versus a Cuban life raft and enabled the
Coast Guard to predict where the things
were and you see these rescue operations
and you always think the rescuer the
people that come down that's right thank
you but it's because of people like art
Allen who can tell you where to go look
to find they wouldn't know where to jump
into the water
it's a little model for the government's
like what you don't see it was gonna say
in a broader sense what does this say to
you about the government that they're
all these functions that we should be
unbelievably proud of by the way yeah
you were so much better off being an
American who's lost on a sailboat
than any other nationality because
because of the work this guy has done
you know and then and then it's been
degraded that he is he's been allowed to
Restall he's in essential yeah he
doesn't have to be in his job and and
then and then he was never given anybody
to train and it isn't just that like we
lost the ability to figure out how
things drift because we now know that
yeah sort of lost something bigger and
it's it's it's this idea that you can
have progress so if you get the people
in government can create this new
knowledge that's a benefit to us all and
it's not only the Coast Guard there are
other divisions of the government doing
good work as well what you spotlight but
so this this risk is poor management
right it's the idea that we're not going
to staff the government as we should and
all these benefits are going to go away
have they been going away so far yes I
mean I think it's you see it you see it
in bits and pieces right now and the
degradation of this enterprise is it's
something like climate change right it's
this very slow moving event and when the
dramatic moments come it's kind of too
late but when you see things like I
don't know the the these Boeing planes
that were not properly regulated you
know when you see the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau being dismantled which
was a direct response to the financial
crisis that everybody at the time agreed
was necessary keep in mind about another
government shutdown what it really means
well and what it means actually to the
bottom half of the society especially I
mean they there's so many people who
depend on this enterprise yeah and it's
it's if you think about it the best way
I think about for me is it manages this
portfolio of risks and some of them are
catastrophic risks yeah and no private
sector enterprise is going to do it and
if you don't value it it's going to come
back to haunt you right nobody wants to
be labeled in essential no one wants to
be taunted after the fact I very good
point
all right thank Michael Lewis thank you
very much the paperback edition of the
fifth risk is on sale right now